robert huffman we're sitting here with
uh the turkey farmer baby this is your
time of year really coming up yeah yeah
we generally uh it's kind of funny we we
get that a lot but uh we're year-round
you know so thanksgiving is just another
another day for us we're pumping turkeys
you know 24 7. oh dang man but dude
people i feel like people like i feed
do you wake up on thanksgiving morning
and you're like fired up and the kids
are all you know you know they're fired
up and people are doing like
turkey calls like is it that kind of a
day for you guys is it how how big of a
of this time of year is uh y'all's
market share basically
uh for our market share it's probably
i don't know maybe and i don't know what
market share means yeah so so generally
we're growing birds year round so if my
flock happens to go out before
thanksgiving or a month before fine if
it doesn't um
it it's probably about
i don't know 30 percent of what a true
turkey farm goes through so around
thanksgiving like is there an extra
batch do you double up on your batches
like starting in like october or
something or you know would you say it's
not 19 weeks 19 weeks so that's that's
for a heavy tom and um if if it's going
for when we're doing like turkeys for
thanksgiving
they're probably they're probably
putting them in they're taking them out
at half that so they're probably going
out around 13 to 15 weeks
a medium-sized bird okay and that's the
one that most people buy for yes that's
what they're gonna buy for thanksgiving
okay and they'll put these specialty
birds just for that and they're they're
medium toms is what they'll call them
damn
yeah and how'd they get the name tom
it's uh genetically i guess that's what
you call you know
a tom and a hen and we'll have hens in
there occasionally because they'll sex
them but they don't always get them
right so you have big old hens
mixed in there with the toms is there
trans turkeys do you start to see that
even in like the turkey uh yeah they
don't really identify other other than
tom and hen and
maybe you know you'll find a dominant
i found hens with beards on them so i
mean maybe they're maybe they're
transitioning oh i found some of them
too around town
i've definitely
one of my buddies had a real issue with
them can i eat a
male
turkey or a female turkey at
thanksgiving can i have either one yeah
potentially it might be either or so i
don't have any ideas yeah wow now my mom
know if it comes in the kitchen and
she's in there doing it yeah you would
never know really yeah
because uh so we sell turkey fries okay
and that's turkey nuts
so they're uh they're they have glands
and their nuts are actually in their
wings
no way yeah so they'll pop them things
out and you fry them up meet them
they good or bad they're good they're
really good yeah i mean they're did they
bust a little or they just kind of now
they just fry them up it's just like you
know eating it yeah like a what this is
like a nugget like a chicken nugget you
got a little thing you get you eat
nuggets is this them right here
yeah wow yeah
yeah they're good man we've we've served
them at numerous meetings we're you know
congressmen and senators and stuff go to
the turkey federation meeting we used to
have them there
i mean i just ate elk nuts like a week
ago because we went out elk hunting and
our guy fixed up a nice uh rocky
mountain elk parmigiana
well i think look joe rogan can
apparently eat his own penis i read the
other day on the internet so
i think at this point everything's
everything's fair game dude if i was
starving i'd eat one of my nuts right
out of my damn body i think you know
because if they feel it feels like you'd
have to heal up good good oh yeah i'd
have one i'm gonna have both of them
like some creep you know damn do native
americans ever look at you as like the
bad like do you ever get billed as like
the bad guy for doing turkey thing not
to my face i mean i got some native
american family members so we're
the the virginia tribes they they still
give a uh a turkey and a deer to the
governor every year oh wow but uh no no
really yeah that's pretty remarkable if
you look that up they'll still do that
uh
um it's like an annual since there's no
reservations or anything in virginia you
know there's just
what's left of us in the that area you
know my uh family members they do the
pow-wows and they'll do nate uh you have
native american family members yes i got
some that are married in and
you know they uh they treat me you know
they're awesome so
i don't have uh
i don't think they were really worried
about nobody's coming at you like you're
a pilgrim no no yeah i didn't think no
you never know what's going on out there
man you never know yeah i have a quick
question for your turkey farmer uh what
does he eat on thanksgiving
because for me if i was processing all
those birds and and getting ready for
this thanksgiving rush i'd be so over it
i'd be like no we're gonna get some
steaks we're gonna get some ham or
something something else um so what does
he do and then if he is turkey then
what's his favorite side because
obviously the birdman is going to know
the best side to go with some turkey uh
so i'm looking for some suggestions
appreciate you
yeah birdman yeah what's the uh what is
it what's the choice from the captain
himself what is it
you know i always joke around with the
guys with the company we eat one of our
turkeys every year so like just before i
come here one of my guys from the
company we kill kill our own birds and
then we keep keep our turkey birds and
we give everybody in the company a free
turkey okay but
with that being said i i mean i've been
lobbying to get some ham maybe partner
up with a
pig company or
check exchange or something yeah y'all
do is there any dark you sneaking over
there at night across the freaking pig
pen or what is there any no no it's not
that uh but do you choose so for
thanksgiving you guys have turkey yes i
i mean i cook a lot of them you know
borderline chef
wife's a chef but uh we we do the i do a
nice infrared so i don't deep fry but i
put them in that infrared and it gets
that crispiness just like a deep-fried
bird without all that oil really is that
the new thing that's delicious is it
yeah because i grew up on that turducken
man and even though i answered we had
damn uh torditos i remember it's like a
turkey and a duck and then they fill it
with cheetos i remember
and i'm like what is this you know
what i'm saying the head damn every
spicy cheetos
uh i think it i couldn't tell i think it
was regular okay yeah because we nobody
in our area ate those jalapeno cheetos
yeah it was more they even have the hot
ones at that point it was just
they were still doing the regular cheeto
you know something to try but that third
item now did that turducken did that
ever hit you do you guys have to do that
no no um i've never i mean i've bought a
turducken you believe in all that it's
not it's okay it's just a lot going on
you got the turkey and chicken and all
that stuff stuffed in there sometimes
i've seen them stuff a quail in that
thing yeah
or i've seen uh terala tarala
geep or whatever it is terala geep it's
turkey alligator and then sheep meat in
it
and i'm like
at some point people are just damn this
is a damn gang bang i feel like you know
what i'm saying like that's a little too
much i feel like if
you get those all those meats and just
cook them primarily alone you can still
do your own mix
yeah you could mix it on your plate like
why do you have to i feel like they give
it robs flavor from one or the other
yeah it's a lot of trial and error there
um
now i like i like my turkey i like to do
it uh you know in that infrared deep
fryer style oilless fryer whatever you
want is it good i've never had that that
sawn it's almost like a sauna so it's uh
it's propane and then it's like one of
those uh
smokeless fire pits you know so now the
smoke comes up and it's like a tube and
you drop the turkey in just like a fryer
and the heat just goes around it and
they crisp it up just press
like that things in barbados or
something i like to inject it with some
marinades get it juicy
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one